[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN 1: It's
your dream scenario.
You've developed an
Android app that's
so compelling and so interesting
that the entire world wants
to use it.
This thing is sure going to
bring you fame and fortune.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN 2:
No, no, no, no, no.
Hold on.
Fame?
Yes.
But fortune?
The money, where's that
going to come from?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN 1:
Didn't think of that.
Udacity offers a course
built with Google
that teaches you
about monetization
strategies for Android apps.
Learn to balance quick wins
with good business models
that support long-term
revenue stream and the value
that the monetization
model has for the user.
This course is all
about the money.
So what are you're waiting for?
Get started now at
udacity.com/google.